je ne sais pas vous mais moi quand
j'étais petit mes parents avaient pour
habitude
malisse pour éviter les crises en public
alors que je m'apparaît à main prêté au
parc a réalisé mon sixième tour de
manège et qu'il n'était pas pour il
avait toujours une alternative
alléchante à me proposer comme par
exemple des friandises ou des gâteaux
quelques années plus tard c'était à mon
tour d'utiliser des méthodes parfois
discutables pour éviter d'avoir à ranger
ma chambre fermée de voir ou encore
finir mon assiette de brocolis
effectivement à l'époque les techniques
utilisées n'étaient pas toujours très
efficiente
mais il m'arrivait de temps en temps
d'avoir des résultats satisfaisants
aujourd'hui à 33 ans
j'utilise le détournement d'attention
quasiment quotidiennement
il s'agit pour moi d'une source
inépuisable d'inspiration me permettant
d'enrichir et d'améliorer ma magie j'ai
étudié ce phénomène et j'ai réussi à
mettre un mot sur cette idée la mise
direction largement utilisé par les
magiciens les mentalistes les
pickpockets
c'est une méthode aussi que l'on peut
utiliser dans la vie de tous les jours
alors l'ami direction c'est quoi c'est
une méthode ou un ensemble de méthodes
qui ont pour objectif d'attirer
l'attention sur une action afin de
réaliser une autre action que l'on
souhaite dissimulé basé sur un principe
simple qu'il est impossible pour l'être
humain d'emmagasiner l'ensemble des
informations qui lui sont proposés alors
quand je parle d'informations
je fais allusion à des signes visuels
auditifs ou kinesthésique
pour étayer un petit peu mes propos nous
allons prendre exemple du personnage de
batman
certes il s'agit d'un personnage fictif
de bande dessinée mais qui a la
particularité d'utiliser que des
méthodes logique est donc étudia bhl
quel rapport entre batman et la mise des
réactions simplement qu'il a pour
habitude de disparaître au nez et à la
barbe de ses interlocuteurs et ce de
manière inexplicable
la plupart du temps il va profiter de
zones adaptées comme des toits des
parkings où il sera difficile de savoir
par où il est parti mais également il va
profiter d'un manque d'attention de ses
interlocuteurs pour pouvoir disparaître
de manière inexplicable alors comment
fait-il en réalité batman contrairement
à superman n'a pas de superpouvoirs
nécessairement ils utilisent des
méthodes dans la trilogie nolan batman a
été initiée par la ligue des ombres
ce qui fait de lui une sorte de ninja
surentraîné
ce n'est pas un choix anodin car parmi
les nombreuses techniques enseignées
dans l'art du ni ni du ninjutsu y
figurent l'eau ninjutsu l'art de devenir
invisible
le principe de base de l'eau ninjutsu
consiste à profiter d'un élément
extérieur pour pouvoir se déplacer vers
l'obscurité jamais même lentement un
exercice de ninjutsu ne pourrait être
réalisé sans ce stimuli extérieurs
qu'ils soient créés ou naturels comme
par exemple le vent un bruit soudain ou
encore un changement de lumière
c'est alors que le ninja ou batman ici
va pouvoir en profiter pour se déplacer
vers l'obscurité donnant l'illusion
qu'il a réussi à disparaître
l'aboutissement militaire ou moderne de
ce type de mise direction pourrait par
exemple être la grenade incapacitante
également appelé grenade
extrasensorielles rendu obligatoire pour
les équipes d'intervention du swat ou du
raid
elles permettent notamment de rentrer
dans un bâtiment hostile pourquoi
obligatoires simplement car au moment
d'entrer dans le bâtiment
l'ensemble des cibles situées à
l'intérieur vont avoir leur attention
ciblées sur l'entrée il serait donc peu
judicieux voire suicidaire d'essayer d'y
parvenir sans utiliser le détournement
d'attention
c'est alors qu'une fois mis en marche la
grenade incapacitante va permettre de
rendre de manière temporaire et de
désorienter l'ensemble des personnes
ciblées par celle ci permettant ainsi
aux équipes d'intervention de rentrer
dans le bâtiment sans trop de dégâts
alors il est vrai que nous n'avons pas
toujours la possibilité d'utiliser ce
type d'outils ou d'artifice et c'est la
raison pour laquelle l'on peut se
demander s'il existe des méthodes ou des
techniques qui permettent de réaliser un
détournement d'attention sans stimuli
extérieurs
la réponse est oui mais il faudra être
beaucoup plus vigilant quant aux
méthodes utilisées et aux techniques
employées c'est pourquoi je voulais
aborder avec vous et vous présenter
trois points clés qui vous permettront
de réaliser un bon détournement
d'attention pour commencer afin de
réaliser deux actions simultanées avec
une différence d'intensité
il faudra prêter attention à vos à votre
gestuelle fluidité naturelle avec une
touche de nonchalance seront un
excellent moyen de réaliser une bonne
mise direction naturel et fluidité
implique évidemment d'avoir une bonne
maîtrise de ses gestuelles mais aussi
d'éliminer le maximum de gestes
superflus d'accord
évidemment aussi éviter d'avoir une
attitude de robots naturel et fluidité
certes mais pas robotisés on va prendre
l'exemple d'un magicien qui voulant
réaliser une manipulation utiliserait
une attitude triomphante
le résultat serait sans doute pas très
convaincant et on pourrait sans doute
voir la manipulation car on serait
attirée par le par la situation alors
que s'ils utilisaient une légère
attitude nonchalante la manipulation
pourrait sans doute mieux passé dans un
second temps les expressions faciales
vont jouer un rôle clé est déterminant
dans la réalisation d'un détournement
d'attention
elles peuvent parfois d'ailleurs joué la
source unique de miss direction demi
direction on va prendre l'exemple de
deux personnes qui en train de discuter
vont avoir un changement radical de
changement d'expressions faciales
passant par exemple d'une colère noire à
un calme olympien ce type de changement
d'expressions faciales va avoir le même
résultat qu'une grenade incapacitante
une temporaire sidération permettant
ainsi à l'interlocuteur d'en profiter
pour réaliser une action secondaire qui
pourra plus facilement dissimuler enfin
la loi de l'intérêt est une des méthodes
les plus utilisées dans l'art de la mise
direction le principe est assez simple
et largement utilisé par les pickpockets
on va c'est pour ça qu'on va on va
prendre l'exemple des pickpockets donc
imaginé un pickpocket qui va avoir
on va rendre pas basé sur un principe
simple qu'on a évoqué un petit peu plus
haut que l'ensemble des informations
sont sont difficiles à emmagasiner pour
l'être humain d'accord donc dans le
cadre de la vision par exemple l'oeil
humain est incapable de se focaliser sur
plusieurs éléments en même temps il va
donc être obligé de se focaliser sur un
point précis et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est naturellement attirés
par le move
on peut donc facilement le tromper en
réalisant deux actions une en mouvement
et une statique dans le cas de
l'audition c'est un petit peu le même
principe on est tous capable de lire
dans des conditions difficiles
prenons l'exemple vous êtes dans un dans
un tramway par exemple vous êtes en
train de lire et vous êtes capable de
faire obstruction à l'ensemble des
stimuli extérieurs pour autant avec un
simple tape au pti vous allez pouvoir
sortir complètement de votre
concentration et donc l'ami direction
peut fonctionner enfin en kinesthésique
les pickpockets utilise régulièrement la
loi de l'intérêt par exemple ils vont
venir vers vous et vous vous demandez
qu'est ce que vous avez dans cette poche
un portefeuille
qu'est ce que vous avez dans la seconde
poche et ils vont en profiter au moment
où vous allez changer d'intérêt pour
vous prendre le portefeuille s'est basée
sur la loi de l'intérêt pour pouvoir un
petit peu mieux vous expliquer son
fonctionnement
on va maintenant réaliser un petit tour
de magie alors c'est un tour de cartes
qui consiste à faire voyager une carte
de manière inexpliquée en utilisant
uniquement le principe de la mise
direction alors je suis venu avec un jeu
de cartes qu'on va pouvoir rapidement
examinée on se connaît pas un voulait
bien regarder s'il vous plaît vous
voulez bien regardez vous pouvez
regarder coupé mélanger prenez votre
temps s'il vous plaît
parfait bon désolé
j'aurais bien pris plus le temps mais et
et on va choisir une carte quelqu'un
connait pas s'il vous plaît vous voulez
bien choisir une carte
alors on se dit c'est une carte
n'importe laquelle elle si elle vous
plaît vous montrez bien tout le monde je
vous laisse faire et on va faire une
petite signature sur la face tenez vous
bien la signer s'il vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à ce soit significatif que pour que
tout le monde puisse bien le voir c'est
bon ouais stylo et la carte parfaite
donc on a bien une carte signée tout le
monde la voit on va simplement la m vers
le milieu du jeu comme ceci mélangé et
on va essayer de la faire voyager
j'espère que vous allez bien voir sous
le jeu regardez ça va aller relativement
vite justice ithaque
j'ai une cartier times je sais pas si on
a vu je ne sais pas si on a vu on va
quand même vérifier si ce docker ouais
je vais leur faire parce que j'étais
vite alors à mettre la carte juste ici 1
2 3
je sais ce que vous dites j'ai peut-être
trichet voulait bien venir vérifier s'il
vous plaît je vous ennuie de ce que je
touche pas je vous laisse regarder
on va leur faire lentement
ça vous allez vous allez bien pouvoir en
profiter regardez je mets le 6 de coeur
je mets un petit peu plus loin vers le
milieu du jeu je secoue un peu
jusqu'où je secoue jusqu'où et si je
secoue suffisamment on se rend compte
que tout le jeu disparaît sauf une carte
avec leur design
alors je sais ce qu'on se dit peut-être
que c'est vous qui avez le devoir d'un
d'autres voulaient bien m'aider à les
couper le jeu vous voulez vous laisse
faire on va mettre les six de coeur au
milieu là comme ça vous pouvez mélanger
pas trop parfait boîte on essaye 17e
position c'est ça ouais non mais je vais
le faire lentement j'ai essayé de pas
triché vous pouvez regarder s'il y est
pour l'instant normalement lié pas sous
la boîte nom parfait
je vous laisse regarder non il est
nouveau sur lui après ce que ça marche
de temps en temps merci alors comme vous
avez pu constater pour réaliser ce tour
il a fallu certes une bonne maîtrise
technique mais avant tout une bonne
maîtrise de l'ensemble des points que
l'on a évoqué tout à leur maîtrise de
l'espace maîtrise des expressions
faciales avec de la joie de la surprise
etc
maîtrise de la fluidité naturelle et
enfin bien sûr de la loi de l'intérêt
qui se fait facilement dans ce tour car
on ne sait pas si la carte est déjà dans
la boîte sous la boîte dans la main du
magicien dans la poche
le doute s'installe rapidement pour
finir et pour un petit peu vous aider
encore plus à réaliser des bonnes mises
direction je voulais aborder avec vous
les trois types de mises direction
qu'ils existent lamy direction du
premier degré se veut assez simple et
elle consiste à réaliser deux actions
simultanées comme on invite à l'heure
avec une attente d'une intensité très
comparable pour exemple on va prendre
une personne qui dans un tabac va
vouloir acheter une rouge
il va compter la monnaie sur le comptoir
actions simples sur lequel il va essayer
de faire focaliser le vendeur et il
pourra en profiter par exemple pour
voler une barre chocolatée action
secondaire à risque qui va vouloir
cacher vise irection du premier degré
pour réaliser une mise érection du
second degré celle ci va être beaucoup
plus visible on va prendre l'exemple
cette fois ci de deux jongleurs qui
auront exactement la même tenue hormis
un point qui les différencie un bouton
d'une autre couleur
la chemise légèrement déchiré et c'est
l'oeil n'est plus seulement attirée par
l'ensemble mais va être captivés par
l'un des deux éléments permettant ainsi
à l'autre de réaliser un détournement
d'attention efficace enfin la mise
direction du troisième degré du
troisième degré se veut quant à elle
total dans le cas des deux ongles heures
on va imaginer que pendant leur show
l'un d'eux va faire tomber sa balle
cette fois-ci lamy direction est totale
et son compatriote va pouvoir en
profiter pour par exemple changer de
costume pour prendre l'exemple du voleur
dans le tabac de tout à l'heure une fois
qu il le racontait tout sa monnaie il va
l'attendre au vendeur et faire tomber
toutes les pièces sur le comptoir
encore une fois la mise direction va
être totale et il pourra en profiter
pour voler une autre barre chocolatée
vous avez une main tenant tous les
éléments pour réaliser une bonne mise
érection la technique le dégré etc
et c'est pourquoi je vous demanderais de
ne pas vous en servir pour voler des
barres chocolatées dans les tabacs par
ailleurs si un jour vous croisez un
jeune garçon qui sous le couvert de ne
pas vouloir finir son assiette de
brocolis utiliserait des méthodes
parfois discutables de miss direction je
vous demanderais de faire comme mes
parents l'ont fait il ya plusieurs
années et de lui laisser penser de temps
en temps qu'il a réussi à détourner
votre attention
[Applaudissements]